the pace of police shootings in 2016 has
accelerated somewhat we've heard about
Eric garner Michael Brown to me a rice
Walter Scott Freddie gray Alton sterling
falando Casteel these names are all
fresh in our minds and people's memories
and the questionable circumstances of
some of these shootings are also in our
minds fatal police shootings of unarmed
suspects caught on video over the last
couple of years have obviously sparked
new outrage and debate in the u.s. over
race and police use of force many claim
that black people are disproportionately
being affected by police use of force
others disagree but data about police
interactions and suspect race isn't as
easy to come by as it should be because
many police departments are unwilling or
even unable to provide it and right now
the federal government in most cases
essentially cannot require local police
departments to supply this type of
information and many police departments
don't even keep records about use of
force during interactions with suspects
often citing a lack of resources even
many pro civil-rights think tanks like
the Center for policing equity
acknowledge that there haven't been
large enough compilations of data to
determine whether or not racial biases
exist in fatal shootings or policing in
general on a national scale without
question there have been individual
studies conducted on specific
jurisdictions throughout the u.s. that
have brought to light some pretty
convincing evidence of racial prejudice
locally such as the recent inquest of
the policing patterns in San Francisco
after officers were found sending tons
of racist text messages to one another
but as far as trying to figure out if
racial bias by police exists today
throughout the country as a whole there
is still a scar city of data and this
prevents us from coming to meaningful
generalized conclusions the energy
behind the black lives matter movement
just stopped killing us
behind the the movement lies the
presumption that race is factoring
causally in the police officers decision
to use deadly force and their encounters
with citizens now in effect the
counterfactual
that's being entertained is
if this person had been white they
wouldn't have been killed now as a
social scientist I recognize that
question no one will ever live in the
parallel universe in which the suspects
in these particular instances were you
know by an experiment or sometimes black
sometimes white we don't have good data
to draw statistical conclusions but we
do have the recordings on the cell
phones of particular incidences 1,000
people are cured by the police in this
country every year 1,000 we have a dozen
videos anecdotes sensationalized cases
perhaps the most egregious cases are the
only ones that come to our attention
should we have a national narrative
leading to large demonstrations and
dozens of cities across the country
leading in some instances to violent
retaliatory actions I'm not blaming that
on the movement I'm just saying it
happens driven by anecdotes let's begin
by breaking down the numbers with regard
to what is probably the most
controversial and frequently discussed
issue right now about police and race
black people being shot and killed by
police and how those numbers compare to
how often white people are being shot
and killed by police
many people who criticize black lives
matter often point out that there are
far more white people being shot and
killed by police than black people and
this is true in 2015 almost twice as
many white people were killed by police
than black people but obviously since
white people are the majority in the US
and black people are a minority we need
to take into account the racial and
ethnic makeup of the u.s. black people
make up 13% of the population but they
constitute 24% of fatal police shootings
black Americans are two-and-a-half times
more likely to be shot and killed by
police than white people and with this
adjustment it may seem that the black
community are victims of obvious bias or
racism in police shootings but another
factor to consider is how often each
race is interacting with and being
arrested by police if a demographic
is being stopped arrested and convicted
of violent crimes at a higher rate than
we can expect that the rate of being
killed by police will be higher
obviously black people do not commit
more crime because they are black
whether or not someone lives in poverty
is a much better indicator of someone's
likelihood to commit crime than his or
her race white people commit more crime
when under the same adverse
circumstances poverty poor schools poor
job opportunities homogeneity of poverty
within a given geographical area lacking
social safety nets as well as histories
of political oppression we must also
consider that profiling and other racial
biases by police are also definitely a
reality in the u.s. but unfortunately in
the u.s. black people are
disproportionately affected by these
historical and economic disadvantages
and they do commit more crime than white
people in general based on the most
recent available Justice Department
statistics black people make up over 28%
of all arrests in the u.s. they make up
thirty-nine percent of arrests for
violent crimes forty-nine percent of
arrests for murder
thirty-four percent of arrests for a
legal weapon possession thirty-four
percent of aggravated assaults and they
make up 55 percent of arrests for
robbery so black people are 13% of the
population they make up twenty eight
percent of all arrests and they make up
even higher portions of violent and
weapons related arrests but they make up
twenty four percent of those shot and
killed by police we recently discussed
on the show a study by a black Harvard
economist Roland fryer which indicated
that there is no racial bias when it
comes to fatal police shootings in the
u.s. it actually concluded that black
people are less likely to be shot and
killed by police than white people in
proportion to how often they interact
with police and are suspected of crimes
the study took into account a number of
important factors when looking at
individual confrontations between
suspects and police including the age of
the suspect whether or not they suffered
from men
illness what crime or crimes the person
was suspected of whether the officer
fired his weapon before or after the
suspect became aggressive and the race
of officers involved as well as other
pertinent factors and still no evidence
could be found that black people are
disproportionately more often the
victims of police shootings relative to
the rate at which they interact with
police however we also mentioned on the
show that this study wasn't as
comprehensive as it could have been and
that more and more data that is less
self-selected is necessary in order to
really have a complete picture of police
shootings and race throughout the
country as a whole
results of other studies have suggested
the presence of racial bias when looking
at more specific parameters which we
will do now a recent study by the
University of South Carolina and the
University of Louisville using 2015 data
collected by The Washington Post shows
that there might be racial bias when it
comes to unarmed suspects who were shot
the study determined that a black person
shot and killed by an officer is almost
twice as likely to be unarmed than a
white person who is fatally shot by
police black and white crime rates have
no bearing on these statistics we're
talking about what happens once the
officer and the suspect are already in
an altercation not only did they find
that black people fatally shot by police
are more likely to be unarmed they
determined that unarmed black people
shot and killed by police are in fact
less likely than white people to be
posing a threat to police during the
altercation one of the authors of the
study criminal justice researcher just
the NIC said quote the only thing that
was significant in predicting whether
someone shot and killed by police was
unarmed was whether or not they were
black crime variables did not matter in
terms of predicting whether the person
killed was unarmed an analogous study
finished late last year by University of
California Davis using similar
methodology and data from 2011 to 2014
found an even bigger disparity
between the likelihoods of black and
white people being shot and killed while
unarmed it found that black people were
three and a half times more likely to be
killed by police when unarmed between
2011 and 2014 let's talk about police
use of force information about deadly
police interactions are an important
metric by which we can gauge racial bias
by police but what about all types of
use of force by officers whether the
suspect was killed or not a three year
study of 19,000 police interactions
between 2010 and 2015 from across the
country found that while only 2% of
police interactions led to any type of
use of force forces being used on black
people at over three times the rate that
force is being used on white people this
applied to every type of force
hand-to-hand altercations use of a
nightstick pepper spray police dog
attacks tasers and gunfire as I
mentioned there are a lot of up-to-date
studies of individual local police
departments that suggest racial bias a
July of 2016 report by the San Francisco
District Attorney's Office that sought
to probe the practices of the SFPD had
some disconcerting findings regarding
the treatment of black people the city
collaborated with Stanford University
and four other law schools and found
unexplainable disparities in the rate at
which black people are stopped searched
and arrested when all relevant variables
were factored out there was no
observable reason in the data as to why
black people in San Francisco were being
targeted at such higher rates it also
determined that this problem has been
getting worse over time in the city like
I said the study was conducted after a
number of SFPD officers were discovered
to have been exchanging racist text
messages quote although black people
accounted for less than 15% of all stops
in 2015 they accounted for over 42% of
all non consent searches following stops
quote of all people searched without
consent black and Hispanic people had
the lowest rate of contraband
after the shooting of Michael Brown the
US Justice Department's investigation of
police in Ferguson Missouri uncovered
quote a pattern or practice of unlawful
conduct within the Ferguson Police
Department that violates the first
fourth and fourteenth amendments to the
US Constitution and federal statutory
law the report discovered that Ferguson
Police were discernibly pulling over in
searching black people at a rate that is
disproportionate to how often they were
finding contraband on black people in
2016 the police accountability task
force in Chicago released a report
finding that quote black and Hispanic
drivers were searched approximately four
times as often as white drivers yet the
Chicago Police Department's own data
showed that contraband was found on
white drivers twice as often as black
and Hispanic drivers lastly a 2015
investigation by the New York Times into
the practices of the Greensboro North
Carolina Police Department found that
quote officers were more likely to stop
black drivers for no discernible reason
and they were more likely to use force
if the driver was black even when they
did not encounter physical resistance so
there is unfortunately a lack of
coalescence in the data from which we
can currently draw larger overarching
conclusions about whether or not and to
what degree there's racial bias in
police shootings in general throughout
the entire United States but there are
some seemingly reliable and
comprehensive studies that have just
come out inferring that racial
imbalances do most likely exist when
measuring specific criteria and there
are definitely definitive sets of proof
within individual jurisdictions of
racism black lives matter may be jumping
the gun in their ability to make certain
specific claims about police shootings
such as that fatal police shootings are
100 percent in every respect without a
doubt unfairly affecting black people
one of the central demands of black
lives matter is for more accountability
and transparency within police
departments
and for them to more consistently report
this type of information to higher
government and the availability of this
data might in fact confirm those
suspicions but this is exactly what we
need I don't think that more discoveries
of racial bias by police throughout the
country as a whole would surprise many
progressives but we're never going to
know for sure until local police are
given the resources and the mandate to
collect the data body cameras mandatory
reports after physical altercations
breakdowns of policing by racial lines
better data infrastructures to track
everything locally and how about more
involvement by the Justice Department
these are crucially necessary steps that
must be taken if we want a complete
picture of how the people of the u.s.
are being treated by police in relation
to their race as incomplete as the
national data may be now there are
definitely plenty of disturbing insights
that we can draw from the solid evidence
that already exists it's important to
know what else we may find if we had
more information to delve into the
current anti police violence movements
may be totally right about sweeping
claims they make and as we've discussed
here we know that there are almost
certainly correct in some cases and it
goes without saying that the shootings
of unarmed suspects that are found to be
unjustified or deplorable like many of
those that have received national
attention after being caught on camera
but we need more data and more studies
to really have a complete picture going
forward regarding how much racial bias
there is and to what scale it exists